Im Universum wurden hundertausende bisher
verborgene Galaxien entdeckt.
Möglich macht das das LOFAR-Projektes in
Europa das im langwelligen Infrarot- und Radiobereich
sucht.
Dabei sind 100.000 Einzelantennen zu einem
gigantischen virtuellen Teleskop zusammengekoppelt,
das so einen Durchmesser von 1.900 Kilometer
hat.
Aufgespürt wurden dabei nicht nur die Galaxien,
sondern auch super spannende Details zu Schwarzen
Löchern!
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich
willkommen!
Konkret macht der europaweite Teleskopverbund
“Low Frequency Array” (LOFAR) eine der
umfangreichsten Himmelsdurchmusterungen überhaupt
möglich.
Hier geht - um es um eine genaue Analyse im
Radiowellenbereich, der bisher wirklich wenig
erforscht ist.
Bei Radiowellen handelt es sich um die längsten
Wellen des elektromagnetischen Spektrums.
Ihre Wellenlänge kann zwischen knapp einem
Millimeter und mehr als einem Kilometer liegen.
Das Ziel von “LOFAR”: Die Erstellung einer
Radiohimmelskarte mit niedriger Frequenz - nämlich
zwischen 10 bis 80 Megahertz und 110 bis 240
Megahertz.
Ein nicht einfaches Vorhaben, für das eine
Menge an Rechenzeit und Teleskopleistung notwendig
ist.
Realisiert hat das LOFAR-Forschungsteam das
Projekt durch die Kopplung von 100.000 Einzelantennen
in ganz Europa - und zwar mit Hilfe eines
Hochgeschwindigkeits-Glasfasernetzes.
So erschufen die Fachleute eine virtuelle
Empfangsschüssel mit einem Durchmesser von
sagenhaften 1.900 Kilometern.
Also ein europäisches Netzwerk an Radioteleskopen,
das alle empfangenen Signale zu einem einzigen
Signal kombiniert.
In Deutschland sind sechs Messstationen zu
finden, unter anderem betrieben von der Universität
Hamburg und der Ruhr-Universität Bochum.
Dazu Dominik Schwarz von der Universität
Bielefeld: “LOFAR produziert unglaubliche
Datenmengen ‒ wir müssen das Äquivalent
von zehn Millionen DVDs verarbeiten.
Dies stellt höchste Ansprüche an Soft- und
Hardware und ist nur durch ein internationales
und interdisziplinäres Team möglich.“
Insgesamt sind rund 200 Astronominnen und
Astronomen aus 18 Ländern an dem Projekt
beteiligt.
Und eine erste Auswertung der Daten zeigt
jetzt, dass sich der ganze Aufwand gelohnt
hat.
Denn die neu erstellte Himmelskarte enthüllt
hunderttausende Galaxien, von denen uns die
meisten bisher unbekannt waren.
Ihre Radiostrahlung hat wohl Milliarden von
Lichtjahre zurückgelegt, denn viele der neu
entdeckten Galaxien liegen extrem weit entfernt.
Und das Projekt “LOFAR” kann einen weiteren
großen Erfolg verbuchen.
Denn durch Radiostrahlung war es erstmalig
möglich, kosmische Magnetfelder, die sich
zwischen diesen zahlreichen Galaxien befinden,
zu kartieren.
Dabei handelt es sich um wirklich enorme magnetische
Strukturen, die bislang lediglich theoretisch
vermutet worden waren.
Dazu der Bonner Forscher Rainer Beck: “LOFAR
liefert Hinweise, dass der gesamte Raum zwischen
den Galaxien magnetisch sein könnte.”
Auch wenn die neue Himmelskarte bislang nur
etwa zwei Prozent der geplanten Beobachtungen
entspricht, konnten in diesem kleinen Ausschnitt
bereits jetzt knapp 325.700 Radioquellen detektiert
werden.
Das ist wirklich sensationell.
Dazu das Forschungsteam: “Die Dichte der
Radioquellen ist damit in dieser Karte um
das Zehnfache höher als bei den sensitivsten
bisher existierenden Radiospektrum-Surveys
mit großem Himmelsausschnitt”.
Doch die Karte kann noch mehr.
Sie wirft auch ein neues Licht auf die supermassereichen
Schwarzen Löcher, die sich im Zentrum von
Galaxien befinden.
Wie genau wechselwirkt das Schwarze Loch und
seine Wirtsgalaxie?
Das ist eine wichtige Frage, zu der Forschungsteams
weltweit tüfteln, und die nun beantwortet
werden konnte.
Denn die aktuellen Radiodaten zeigen, dass
sogenannte Jets in jeder großen Galaxie zu
finden sind - sogar in unserer Milchstraße,
wie erst vor kurzem bekannt wurde.
Diese Materialstrahlen namens Jets sind vor
allem im Radiobereich sichtbar und bestehen
aus beschleunigten Teilchen.
Sie entstehen, wenn Schwarze Löcher Materie
einsaugen.
Die hohe Empfindlichkeit von LOFAR enthüllte
zudem, dass diese Schwarzen Löcher ständig
wachsen.
Enthalten schwarze Löcher die Weltformel?
Um dazu mehr zu erfahren, draufklicken, anscheun
und Neugierzone abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!